didn't Prime Minister sit on a VM for  being enable tact sweetness let our  African community down in the United  States I watched the tapes of face of  rocking he was being followed in  harassed by troublemakers three rocky  okay this is a joke  it's illegal for for example Stefan let  me interpret it involve himself I think  it's the same in us actually  he cannot involve himself either it will  be illegally in the US as well so it's  very strange that he tweets and says  that he is disappointed and so on it's  like a typical [ __ ] comment and yeah we  see these kind of comments from him all  the time like in very egocentric and he  wants to do whatever he wants to it's  laughable really it's typical of him I  would say yes  not much respect here in this country